islam net is raising funds to establish
a masjid and community center in norway
every person who prays there every kid
that learns about islam every youngster
that memorizes the quran all of this and
so much more can be on your scale of
good deeds click the link and donate
what you can
[Music]
and i came across this uh gentleman and
i said to him he looked atheist
and he said how did you know i gave it i
said i just guess
you don't have any looks
no it's just the you know yeah
what's your name my name is tom tom hi
my name is ali alex nice to meet you man
you look like a very jolly guy
you look like you're like a
happy-go-knocking guy i like life yeah
yeah yeah yeah saturday in london
how long have you been in london it's
been in london 10 weeks now oh 10 weeks
how do you find it you're from scotland
edinburgh so yeah coming down here the
scots are very close-minded really yeah
bro i mean oh yeah
they've got a long-term people
[Laughter]
my friends were worried about me coming
down here it really was because of the
fact that this car said english we were
like english must hate the scots right
come down here
open arms nice
london is like that it's very diverse
even without like people from our
background etc yeah yeah
what was your name sorry talk tom trump
how are you 21 21 yeah you've got 21
seconds to go yeah
you're studying working i'm working
right now internship uh what are you
doing asset management so i'm in asset
manager i wanted to be a stock broker i
studied banking and finance yeah but
then i left it it's uh it's a doggy dog
what would you say your purpose in life
is my purpose in life
i'd like to just have a
an open mind
about everything just
experience as many things as i can don't
leave anything to regret
i always i like um making decisions i
don't like or maybe ghana yes or no but
i like making a decision okay
are you some someone where when you're
certain about something yeah you got
pulled out yeah interesting i'm a bit
like that as well yeah i came to islam
about eight and a half years ago
and i spent about three years looking
into it yeah i had to be sure just the
right and once i put my head down i was
like okay
where are you at with a creator have you
ever had a moment where you thought you
know hold on a second where did all this
come from what am i doing here who put
me here have you ever had those moments
so my mom my mom's a strong catholic
they're irish
we've had conversations about you know
why are we here you know
when
our time runs out what happens post that
like deep conversation with the guys
yeah never had any answers because no
one really i mean people have in my
opinion people have different solutions
yeah
and different answers in their opinion
it's like i'm obviously open to here
i'm interested to find out i'll be
honest okay so look
i
okay so would you accept that there is
some kind of higher power i'd like to
hope there is yeah yeah i'd like to
agree with this yeah you liked you i'd
like to hope there is something yeah
okay that's good what we call that is
the pitra in islam it means your innate
disposition right so we believe every
human being is created with that desire
to want god yeah there was a study done
in oxford i can't remember exactly the
name of the
thing with names yeah yeah so
the study that i was done with they got
a group of people kids
at a certain age yeah and what they did
is they realized that
all of them if you don't tell them about
islam christianity or judaism or any of
that that they all believed in a higher
being it was indeed really yes it was
innate it was studied in
the
oxford
yeah so it showed you that human beings
by nature we're not told about god it's
inside us yeah so our innate disposition
is
to have that that's the reason why we're
in trouble
we turn to a higher mean yeah because we
realize logically i'm not going to pray
[Music]
yeah so now what i would say tom is that
look this is how i do it there's an
argument from contingency right
there are dependent things in our
universe yeah right yeah there are
things that depend yep now the best way
i can explain this is the following yeah
yeah can we have
c without a seedbed
no because it all lays backwards
so now i want you to imagine
google yeah can google operate without
the internet being
existing yeah no it can't
okay can the internet exist without a
computer or an ipad or whatever it may
be cheating in the age okay yeah can the
computer exist without electric
no okay so these see google are
something dependent
it depends on what the internet
the internet depends on the computer
yeah the computer depends on electric
and electric
depends on obviously
us human beings and other factors yeah
so what that shows is that
these dependent things
ultimately require
a necessary beam for all it to make
sense because it's like a chain
it's like a chain of like events that
like yeah so we can't have an infinite
amount of dependent things yeah so it
wouldn't make sense yeah we are infinite
rigorous fallacy yeah so we ultimately
require a independent
being
that is not defending anything for all
for everything to make sense yeah yeah
yeah so what we're saying is that is god
almighty yeah that's the creator yeah
and we all of us dependent things rely
on him and he's independent and he's
self-sufficient that's why allah says in
the quran
say he is one right self-sufficient yeah
he does not beget nor is he begotten and
there is nothing like him so now the
christians and the catholics what they
believe is god came down as a man jesus
yeah
we say that doesn't believe god's nature
because firstly what did we say he's
independent yeah self-sufficient yeah
jesus walked to earth he was dependent
on food he was dependent on sleeping
yeah
so he can't be there god almighty
do you get it yeah yeah so that's the
reason why we say that god almighty says
in the quran if there was more than one
word they would fight each other for
power yeah so that's why we believe
there has to be ultimately one god
that's independent
and all of us rely on him for our
existence so so you're saying
independence what was the other one
self-sufficient yeah self-sufficient
self-sufficient yeah it could have he
could have not been any other way and
he's not composed of parts okay so
anything within our universe is compared
to some sort of part yeah yeah so as in
the criteria why why is it those two is
that something that's just like
independent self-sufficient well there's
well the thing is because if he was not
independent oh that's a computer yeah if
he wasn't then he'll be dependent okay
he's dependent he's not good he cannot
be a creator
what does he depend on the moment we say
he's a creator and he
depends on something that renders his
he's not a goal of mine because now he
depends on that's the reason why we say
to the christians yeah jesus cannot be
god or we say to the hindus hare krishna
is not god they believe god is a boy
with a flu yeah yeah or i don't pagans
who believe in idol because we say these
are man-made thoughts so so what is so
is a hindu where they have like millions
of gods yeah yeah looks good right okay
so what we see is
that is
false right and only that that is
actually um in gratitude discretion in
gratitude to god almighty yeah because
he's the one who sustains you and gives
you life and you go to a tree or a
statue and say thank you yeah oh jesus
thank you when you should be glorifying
the one who killed you
yeah yeah yeah so yeah that's where we
come from but do you have any questions
or like no i think that's that's a nice
way but i never really
for me
it's hard to
believe in something unless you can see
it i i know that's such a like
rash bold statement to me yeah if i
generally
had some kind of sign one day and i was
like this must be something like you
know exactly like okay there's a lot of
things that we believe in what we don't
see yeah so for example
love
love is something it's not absolutely
it's abstract yeah yeah yeah but we
believe it exists even though we don't
see it it's subjective as well exactly
yeah also our conscious yeah can you see
my consciousness
can i see yours
so do we deny that we have a conscious
mind yeah
yeah so scientists have a little they
grapple with this it's called the hard
problem of consciousness okay they can't
get their mind around how we have a
conscious mind and you know trying to
say yes yes so so what we're seeing is
in a nutshell that there are things that
we believe exists that we can't see yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so in that
is that what you would say was stopping
you like like seeing god yeah no not
yeah i don't know i've just never
done enough research to fully
grasp it and then i was kind of just
like sitting on the fence the whole
thing because i wasn't either completely
against story completely for it
i was kind of like i would hope there is
well that's good but that's good because
yeah exactly
yeah have you read the quran before i've
never but i've got a few friends here
yeah yeah
i'll give you this as a gift oh wow do
you have any questions about islam
anybody would like to know
um
fat is fasting so yeah
yeah right okay yeah how long is that
for
it changes from time if this is summer
yeah
from sunrise to sunset
[Music]
like basically that's sacrifice okay
whatever we do yeah there are wisdoms
behind it okay but even if there's no
wisdom we do it because god told us to
okay now if you have someone who's
created heavens in the earth yeah and he
told you not to do something he's
deserving of being listened to yeah
because of who he is yeah yeah so it's
like your mum and dad do something yeah
yes he listens to them because of who
they are yeah and what they've done yeah
but because of who god is and how
magnificent he is
he's created heavens in the earth yeah
he's creating our universe he's telling
me to just i'm going to do that now
doing that it's not because he needs it
okay he does that because in this life
it's a test yeah
yeah yeah yeah of course and we possibly
said and allah says to us and the
prophet said that my fasting slave that
he will reward us specifically for that
and we believe in the hereafter
we believe there's hell in heaven yeah
yeah and we will be
we're tested in this life and god has
given us the faculties and his signs are
everywhere to find him
so so he will ask us how you live your
life yeah
you know why did you not turn to me you
know worship me
yeah yeah so that's why we like you know
fast yeah and stuff like that yeah
[Music]
wow that's very kind do you have any
more questions feel free to yeah but why
don't we open the quran unless you maybe
there might be a message in there for
you who knows i'll read it on the tube
yeah yeah no problem one verse now and
maybe just a point at it yeah
point me at two of us let's see
64. 64. okay
this is
okay
okay let's
okay
to him just the verse before he says
do you not see that allah has sent down
rain from the sky and the earth becomes
green indeed allah is
aware this is the verse you picked so
him belongs what is in the heavens and
what is on the earth and indeed allah is
free of need to praise worthy what did
we discuss about independence yeah yeah
remember yeah so here god is saying to
him belongs to what is in the heavens
and the earth this one belongs to him
yeah us
in the universe here
and indeed allah is free of need the
praiseworthy so he's self-sufficient
yeah he doesn't need anything yeah we
need him yeah that's very interesting
yeah yeah and then 65 says do you not
see that allah has subject subjected to
you whatever is on the earth and the
ships which run through the sea by his
command and he restrains the sky from
falling upon the earth unless by his
permission indeed allah to all people is
kind and merciful yeah
and lastly and he and he's the one who
gave you life and he causes you to die
and then will again give you life indeed
mankind is ungrateful yeah yeah so allah
says this allah says mankind is
ungrateful to his mother because we
can't we enjoy all the blessings of life
etc but we don't give him thanks we
don't acknowledge him yeah you know and
that's the message in a nutshell i don't
want to keep you any longer uh tom enjoy
yourself um thank you very much i really
appreciate your time it's cold not many
people like speaking but i appreciate
you look like an honest person that's
open-minded and i hope god guides you
and if you do believe in him and i'm
sure you do do one thing pray and say
god if you're there guide me to the
truth and maybe we'll see you in about a
couple of weeks
i'll be back
we're doing luke's holiday yes time it's
a pleasure we're here every saturday my
name is ali dawa i'm on youtube yes this
video might be there on my channel on
youtube so yeah check it out i'll do it
now yeah check out